o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
nós estamos em 2021 tem 62 anos número
para meninos e pessoas com 50 anos eram
velhas com 60 mas o tempo é o senhor da
Razão as 50 anos decidi fazer uma
vasectomia e seguir tudo roteiro de
exames para conseguir o resultado da
intervenção tudo certo preocupado e
gozar a vida
há dez anos depois às vésperas de
completar 60 anos super premiado com uma
reflexão natural o inesperado do trouxe
nos braços e amiga que não ser em casa
as minhas mãos uma das experiências mais
sublimes
a minha primeira filha Jéssica achei
1986 no lapso de tempo de 32 anos entre
a existência dessas duas mulheres da
minha vida consome bem algumas locações
enfrentei criminosos realizei alguns
sonhos sofrem atentados e cheguei aqui
junto a vocês para manifestar meu
inconformismo e tem sábio conquistar
realizadores de mudanças
Olá neste 1979 com o clube de oratória e
reverência de Joinville prático
voluntariado formando curadores e
ficando a Jéssica agora com 34 anos foi
a mais jovem diretora desta ONG e
transformou-se numa mulher condenada
excelente orador
a versão 2008 como Instituto vivacidade
copiei essa prática voluntária Rosa
agora focado no meio ambiente promovendo
conscientização e educação ambiental EA
Mira com apenas dois anos de idade EA
mais jovem associada dessa alcipe
ambientalista
e também às vésperas dos seus 50 anos
conclui a faculdade de jornalismo são
profissional descobrindo atividade
Empresarial iniciado AOS 7 anos de idade
com o editor de jornais naturalmente foi
mexendo de ser empresário para assumir
jornalista foi caminhando para
convergência se completando assim o
torneio um dos poucos Jornalistas
investigativos do país focado em
questões ambientais
o vídeo e prêmios de Jornalismo e eles e
muitas denúncias de crimes ambientais
têm enfrentado grupos poderosos
nacionais e multinacionais já sofre
atentado ameaças com revólver na minha
cabeça e rotineiras ações judiciais em
2013 um amigo jornalista foi encontrado
morto em quarto de hotel em
Florianópolis onde iríamos montar a
estratégia de uma denúncia internacional
contra a maior fundição da América do
Sul pela prática de crimes ambientais no
ecossistema da Vitória
o que mais uma vez a morte chegou muito
perto de mim atualmente o maior
Condomínio Empresarial da América Latina
e processa por pelo denunciado em
matéria jornalística é como alguns
poderosos fazem para tentar calar quem
nos enfrenta temos desse muda e quantas
Fatos e um acontecendo na minha vida aos
49 anos de idade torneio educador
ambiental voluntário do Governo do
Estado no curso de formação realizada em
São Francisco do Sul promovido pelo
comitê temático do desenvolvimento
econômico sustentável de Santa Catarina
e assim então integra o grupo de
trabalho de educação ambiental da região
hidrográfica da Baixada Nordeste
há 58 anos torneios signatário do
movimento nacional dos objetivos do
desenvolvimento sustentável e da agenda
2030 da Organização das Nações Unidas
ONU
e trata-se de um movimento social
constituído por voluntários com a
finalidade de contribuir para a melhoria
da qualidade de vida da humanidade
ajudando a construir comunidades
socialmente inclusivas ambientalmente
sustentáveis e economicamente
equilibradas e aos 59 anos a representar
um instituto uma cidade no
importantíssimo movimento o grupo pro
bactomia gpb gpb um colegiado que une
comentários dos segmentos
sócio-ambiental público e
sócio-econômico no amplo processo de
gestão ambiental participativa do
ecossistema Vitória viu logicamente
apresento neste segmento o
socioambiental
e com 61 anos imprimir isolamento social
imposto pela pandemia do 19 passei por
uma formação do programa das Nações
Unidas para o desenvolvimento e
tornei-me acelerador e consultor dígitos
desenvolvimento sustentável do Sul RS
é com esta nova atribuição conseguir
sensibilizar o grupo pro babitonga e
também se tornou signatário do Sul RS
Olá neste grupo Encontramos uma rica
diversidade de voluntários pesquisadores
professores empresários e cientistas
pesquisadores igual o grupo pro
babitonga também defende este
ecossistema que é o território
compreendido pela lâmina d'água da Baía
babitonga até os limites de ocorrência
de vegetação de manguezal presentes 26
municípios da região Nordeste de Santa
Catarina Araquari Balneário Barra do Sul
Garuva Itapoá Joinville e São Francisco
do Sul
é classificado pelo Ministério do meio
ambiente como área prioritária para
conservação utilização sustentável e
repartição dos benefícios da
biodiversidade o ecossistema concentra
75 por cento dos manguezais do estado do
Catarinense
e se você não sabia a baía babitonga um
estuário e como tal tem uma importância
planetária que a maioria de nós
moradores desse ecossistema não
reconhece
e na babitonga reproduzem tinta centro
das espécies risadas pela pesca
recreativa Industrial se perguntar mesmo
para os pescadores quantas Ilhas têm no
ecossistema babitonga alguns virão
outros 20 outros ainda 30 após Este é um
dos mais belos patrimônios naturais do
planeta contemplado com 206 Ilhas sim
Vocês ouviram bem 206 milhas
E apesar disso nós que moramos aqui
nesse ambiente ainda não aprendemos a
dar o devido valor ambiental turístico e
terapêutico ao nosso ecossistema
e a baía babitonga também abriga áreas
de cultivo de moluscos muitas famílias
de diversas comunidades nos municípios
do Entorno deste Paraíso tem a pesca
artesanal como única atividade econômica
São 50 comunidades que totalizam mais de
1.500 pescadores artesanais A Pesca
Industrial realizada em mar aberto entre
a capital Catarinense Florianópolis eo
litoral paranaense tendem dependem deste
ecossistema como a área de reprodução e
recrutamento da grande parte das
espécies aula
o ecossistema babitonga ambientamento
ambientalmente frágil e abriga espécies
estão ameaçadas de extinção entre elas a
Toninha o boto-cinza a tartaruga-verde
Homero o bagre Branco a miraguaia O
maçarico de papo vermelho o
bicudinho-do-brejo o Guará o cenário
formado por paisagem belíssima composta
quinta 206 vírgulas de praias espaços de
lazer e contemplação é palco também de
outras atividades econômicas como
mineração turismo e Glória
de babitonga já conta com três terminais
Portuários Porto de Itapoá a Porto de
São Francisco do Sul e Terminal Marítimo
da Petrobras Transpetro a Bahia está
atraindo investidores e as políticas
públicas estão a serviço bests interesse
sem prejuízo do patrimônio natural
e mais 12 vou repetir além dos três
terminais já existentes mais 12
Empreendimentos estão sendo licenciados
ou com pedido de avaliações sendo feitos
esses Empreendimentos que não consideram
os impactos ambientais cumulativos na
Bahia estão idealizando por exemplo a
pesca artesanal
e a milenar profissão está sendo afetada
e centenas de pescadores perderam suas
fontes de renda de sobrevivência
e os investidores também estão te
roubando manguezais que são protegidos
por lei diz mais que o poder econômico
aliado a governos que priorizam o PIB
com servem autorização escritório não
agressões criminosas contra o meio
ambiente em atividade legal
é uma prática recorrente do
desenvolvimento não-sustentável
e é por isso que convido todos vocês
apoiarem as pessoas e instituições que
lutam pela criação da área de Proteção
Ambiental da babitonga
e não têm sido poucas as vezes que estão
do outro lado de ecochato ouvir o
desagradável então vou falar a linguagem
do capitalismo estudo de valoração
econômica dos serviços ecossistêmicos
elaborado em uma 197 atribuiu o valor
anual áreas naturais incluindo
manguezais e estuários
é um base nesses estudos O valor é no
Alves manguezais da babitonga e do
complexo estuarino seria d958 milhões
62970 dólares convertendo para nossa
moeda o valor econômico de serviços
ecossistêmicos produzidos pela Baía
babitonga é de seis bilhões de reais
pura
a minha somatória de todos os
Empreendimentos previstos com já
existente seria capaz de gerar lucros
tão fantástico para nossa comunidade
para o nosso planeta
e portanto não tenho dúvidas não só
temos argumentos Bill desagradáveis que
já enumerei mas também por esse
extraordinário valor monetário
apresentar é imperativo é urgente e
digital que seja criada a unidade de
conservação do ecossistema longa e essa
minha atual e mais motivadora outra essa
causa que faz me sentir só vem tão jovem
e meu corpo vibra na mesma frequência e
Rompe Barreiras fazendo me pai e 60 anos
de idade também polícia estou aqui uma
visão de gente que faz a diferença e
suas em com formadas pessoas namorada
um daqueles 30 anos 90 quero fazer
mergulhar na Bahia desejo Remar e quem
sabe nadar ao redor do Eixo das ilhas
Navegar ao lado das Toninhas botos para
poder contemplar Os Vermelhos guarda
Asus céus da Bahia e Os Verdes
tartarugas baianas ousadas
bom então por uma sociedade
ambientalmente sustentável e
economicamente Que hora que o
ecossistema babitonga continue
repartindo os benefícios dessa
exuberante biodiversidade com o restante
do planeta ocorrido todos que possam se
sentir realizadores de mudanças que nos
unamos pela criação da APA da Bica
É sim 50 ela está com vocês desfrutando
de toda essa rica biodiversidade
os jogos estaremos aqui respirando o ar
puro deste Eco Sistema perfumado apenas
pela Maresia da babitonga
e em 2050 quero sempre estar aqui neste
ambiente beijando e abraçando uma
criaturinha que ainda não está nesse
mundo minha netinha filha de outra
mulher o beirada filha da minha amiga
e por mim por você pelas crianças que se
aconchegam em nossos colos rapa da
babitonga já